bonsoir à tous ceux nous sommes le
mercredi 9 mars merci de nous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le
journal comme chaque jour le point sur
votre actualité locale avec nos invités
mais également les journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite les titres de
cette édition
aujourd'hui mercredi 9 mars le test de
la rue pour la réforme du travail
syndicats salariés étudiants ils sont
nombreux à être descendus dans les rues
pour protester contre le projet de loi
de myriam el khomri le point dans cette
édition à suivre avec également comme
invité bertrand degré président du medef
des yvelines et cette semaine mais est
ce qu a que les journées andy fac
objectif sensibiliser la communauté
universitaire au handicap
l'auteur de berre de bd georges grard
s'est déplacé pour une séance de
dédicaces il est le premier à avoir mis
en scène des héros de bandes dessinées
handicapés et enfin la journée
internationale des droits de la femme a
été l'occasion pour la fédération
française de cyclisme de présenter son
plan de féminisation de la discipline
retour sur la soirée organisée mardi
soir au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines démonstration
de l'équipe de france bat m sur piste et
ateliers et est au programme et
l'actualité de ce jour c'est bien sûr le
mouvement de grève une mobilisation
importante des salariés syndicats
étudiants ou encore chômeurs qui a lieu
un peu partout en france en cause le
projet de loi sur la réforme du travail
proposé par la ministre du travail mme
myriam el khomri cette réforme est loin
de faire l'unanimité une pétition contre
celle-ci posté sur le site internet et
chaînes jetant un regard déjà recueilli
plus d'un million de signatures
l'étape suivante c'était bien sûr la
mobilisation dans les rues de paris qui
a eu lieu aujourd'hui pour en parler ce
soir avec nous bertrand de créer
président du medef des yvelines
bonsoir à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous livrer votre
analyse sur cette réforme et vos
impressions dans quelques instants
mais avant cela je propose de revenir
sur la manifestation contre l'avant
projet de loi sur la réforme du code du
travail du travail pardon chômeurs
travailleurs et étudiants se sont réunis
pour cette manifestation place de la
république à 14h manifestation toujours
en cours patrick jacques de dixmude et
william est là sont allés prendre la
température et garder
étudiants comme un spectre c'est bien
l'appel à la manifestation du 9 mars
place de la république à paris a été
entendue
un rassemblement sans réelle
organisation mais un seul objectif
aujourd'hui tous dans la vie unis face à
el comment il n'y a rien de bon là
dedans que celui qui trouve un seul truc
en faveur des travailleurs qu'il le dise
il n'y a rien pour les travailleurs
doute paul ellis pour les patrons on est
entrepreneur reina ras-le-bol de ça la
pétition c'est très bien mais ça va la
déchiqueteuse
il va falloir des grèves des
mobilisations des manifestations parce
que ces gens là ils ne comprennent pas
les discussions dans les rangs des
syndicats et des partis de gauche qui
manifestent aujourd'hui contre la
politique d'un gouvernement socialiste
manifestation dont les lycéens et
étudiants se sont emparés
aujourd'hui c'est important d'être dans
la rue puisque la loi travail c'est tout
simplement un recul de 70 ans en arrière
sur le droit des travailleurs et que
c'est la précarité pour les jeunes et
pour les étudiants aujourd'hui se
mobiliser c'est la seule solution pour
pour gagner pour gagner de nouveaux
droits pour les jeunes et pour empêcher
que ces touareg récit se passe autre est
non négociable est demandée par la
grande majorité des syndicats une
manifestation aujourd'hui qui sera un
véritable thermomètre social pour le
gouvernement
nous demandons qu'il y a un travail de
discussion et des mesures qui soient
prises mais pas celle de ce texte dont
tu te demandes gouvernement de
comprendre et d'entendre que ce texte
n'est pas bon il leur vote y est on
discute ce que nous voulons pas c'est le
statu quo mais auxerre gouvernement de
gauche qui fait une politique de droite
moi je fais pas la différence est que
sarkozy nous on est pas de cette
majorité on l'a jamais été au niveau du
parti gauche et de jean luc mélenchon
donc c'est pas aujourd'hui que ça va
changer au contraire donc on serait ravi
de faire tomber ce gouvernement qui a
commencé timidement à 14 heures mais qui
a vu ses rangs grossir jusqu'à recouvrir
l'ensemble de la place de la république
avant un départ vers la place de la
nation
en bref ce sont environ 150
manifestations qui est prêt
nous sommes alors les chiffres de la
mobilisation n'ont pas encore été
définies n'est communiquée mais
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes à peu près 20 me et est au
rendez-vous bertrand de créer vous
comprenez cette mobilisation
g j'ai un peu de mal j'ai un peu de mal
à vous répondre parce que alors ce que
je crois d'abord un je veux mes frais
c'est pas une loi pour le medef
nous critiquons certains aspects nous
pensons seulement que c'est un premier
pas qui va dans le bon sens mais je
pense qu'elle a été très mal à mener
très mal à mener et il ya eu très peu de
pédagogie d'un homme réclame la
discussion il aurait peut-être fallu la
discussion préalable pour faire
comprendre parce que quand j'entends ce
que les manifestants de votre reportage
j'entends soi-disant d'arrière dit
l'étudiant mais se fait pas je n'ai pas
pu y fait référence sur des en arrière
je parce qu'il ya cent dix ans quand il
part de précarité c'est tout le
contraire
c'est tout le contraire la précarité
c'est le chômage l'emploi c'est pas la
précarité baisser les salaires j'ai pas
vu que cette loi baisser les salaires
au contraire cette loi elle est fait
pour
alors il ya certains aspects de la loi
je dis bien pas tout mais sans aspect
qui permettent de sécuriser l'entreprise
et je voudrais aussi qu'on parle d'une
chose il faut arrêter parce que on a
entendu le choisit le premier client qui
disait les riches les patrons les
entreprises patronat en général et
notamment pierre gattaz du président
national du média cd plutôt satisfait de
cette fois vous ne partagez pas cette
opinion non mais si je vous le dis elle
va dans le bon sens notre niveau de ses
actions et sur le fait qu'elle aille
dans le bon sens
donc on va pas taper sur le truc vous
dire que cette loi ne satisfait
pleinement et pierre gattaz d'ailleurs
ne dit pas qu'elle ne s'est pleinement
elle va dans le bon sens c'est tout de
mon propos de partage parfaitement le
pineau mon président les points positifs
de cette loi selon vous alors les points
positifs il y en a il y en a il y en a
plusieurs
il y en a qui est celui du plafonnement
des ânes des prud'homales
attendez on parle pas de moi on parle
d'un an et demi quand même ligne mais
non pas du tout pas du tout je pense
qu'il va dans le sens de la société
c'est quand un employé perd son travail
c'est qui puisse le retrouver le plus
vite possible
donc si il touche un an de salaire ou
six mois de salaire l'important c'est
pas qu'il vit avec ses six mois où c'est
un an
l'importance qu'ils trouvent du travail
tout de suite donc il a touché six mois
de salaire ou à un an de salaire soit
leur ancienneté
il va être ultra ils vont être trois
mois il faut se mobiliser là dessus
c'est là qu'il faut se mobiliser
c'est sur la formation des gens sur la
capacité à créer de l'emploi et la
qualité à ce que les gens se demande
d'emploi que la vraie précarité c'est le
chômage
l'intention du gouvernement de mieux
adapter justement a le droit du travail
aux tpe pme
beaucoup de gens se sont félicités
notamment les petits artisans
vous serez également une bonne chose un
peu plus d'effort est d'abord un encore
idées reçues
le medef est composé à 96 % de pme tpe
de moins de 10 salariés
d'accord donc nous sommes
parce que je ne cesse de le répéter sur
ce plateau le cac 40 c'est 40
entreprises point à la ligne
il y en a 40 par définition la france et
ça et c'est l'énorme insee qui vous le
dise il suffit de chercher sur google
l'insee taïz entreprise et vous
apercevez que 96 38 françaises ont moins
de 10 salariés
donc la france est un pays de pme tpe
donc l'entreprise française sont des pme
tpe d'eau je ne peux que me facilitez me
féliciter excusez-moi de mesure 1 je
suis patron d'une pme et l'intégralité
à une exception près des adhérents du
medef des yvelines sont des patrons de
pme et de tpe
justement vous en tant qu' en tant que
patron qu'est ce que cette loi vous
apporter ce que concrètement
pratiquement voulu dire des avantages
peut-être pour vous alors j'ai la chance
d'avoir une activité moi qui est assez
régulière
je ne nie pas soumis à des variations
c'est celle des chances que qu'à mon
entreprise et en ce qui me concerne le
tout le volet qui permet d'adapter de
licenciement économique en cas de baisse
d'activité d'entreprises jeudi serait
jamais puisque moi j'ai la chance
d'avoir un os qui progresse qui va bien
qui embauchent donc à titre personnel
pas mais je pense que beaucoup
d'entreprises que je connais qui
justement sont soumis à cet effet de
commandes de vont pouvoir moduler et ça
ça peut être une chance parce que vous
savez quand on quand on est englué
dirais avec une décharge et d'écouté qui
font que l'entreprise perd de l'argent
si elle en perd trop un moment elle
dépose le bilan
c'est assez simple à comprendre et quand
elle dépose le bilan
tous les emplois sont cassé tous alors
moi je préfère d'entreprise qui passe de
a les 50 à 40 salariés pendant une
période parce que c'est difficile qui
vive
et quand elles reprennent le haut de la
vague qu'elle permette ont rembauché les
vins les 30 où les 40 et se dépasser
ce qui m'intéresse et ça aussi c'est une
chose qu'il faut qu'on
prendre il n'y a pas de combat entre un
patron et ses salariés
nous vivons une chose commune un chef
d'entreprise il n'y a qu'une envie c'est
de voir progresser son entreprise et
d'embouché parce que si s'ils
développent si l'embauché qui l'a
développé l'entreprise
je connais pas un patron qui puisse me
dire moi j'ai envie de régresser
monsieur j'ai envie de régresser j'ai
envie de virer des gens parce que j'aime
pas les employés ça n'existe pas ça
c'est juste dans la rue qu'on entend des
choses comme ça vous paraît tout le foot
alors justement du du chômage selon le
gouvernement cette réforme du code du
travail est nécessaire notamment pour
lutter contre la hausse du chômage
axel de personnes qui est secrétaire
général du syndicat cgt des cheminots
trap est venu hier au plateau
il nous en parlait justement je propose
d'écouter cet extrait où il parle du
chômage
aujourd'hui si on veut faciliter les
licenciements
on va pas créer des emplois tout ce qui
va se passer c'est qu'on va faciliter
les licenciements et au contraire on va
supprimer encore plus d'emplois c'est la
seule conséquence que ça va avoir
évidemment ça va aussi donner une
latitude encore plus importante pour
l'employeur qui a déjà faut le rappeler
quand même tous les pouvoirs dans une
entreprise il a le pouvoir de direction
d'organisations de sanctions ça va lui
donner encore plus de latitude pour
imposer ses projets face à des salariés
qui seront encore plus démunis du point
de vue de la loi pour se défendre
c'est tellement une réaction à propos
pour moi c'est caricatural
c'est issu d'un autre âge c'est
totalement à côté de la plaque
attendez je vaux à écouter ce monsieur
on pourrait croire que l'entrepreneur ou
le chantre 8 veut licencier mais je ne
connais pas un seul pas comme ça je ne
connais pas un seul cas devant le
patronat où les entrepreneurs c'est plus
de flexibilité mais on peut comprendre
que cette flexibilité peut aussi amener
au chômage
cette fille si elle amène à la limite le
chômage aujourd'hui il existe toutes les
mesures et toutes les protections qu'on
a mis non on amène leur a coûté
aujourd'hui pour l'instant on peut pas
dire que on était tellement écouté ce
que je constate c'est quand même que le
chômage augmente de plus en plus donc on
est vraiment mauvaise voie on le sait
maintenant ça c'est un constat
maintenant je dis nous disons
aujourd'hui que m'étonner en plus plus
pourront être agile
plus nous pourrons être rassurés plus
nous pourrons voir l'avenir parce que
qu'est-ce qu'un chef d'entreprise sait
qu'il regarde l'avenir quand il va
investir quand ils empochent une
personne cet investissement
un investissement pour l'entreprise si
il est sécurisé sur investissement il le
fera aujourd'hui on peut en bloquant et
en mettant des barrières et bien les
patrons n'embauchent pas donc le chômage
augmente et ça continuera
l'important joulié tout à l'heure c'est
de pouvoir que demain mais si demain une
entrevue ce que j'attendais la lutte et
les deux mondiale a aujourd'hui on est
sur une compétition mondiale avec des
chinois des indiens des américains des
celui-là mais enfin bon la planète la
planète et et cette lutte stafa combat
on doit la gagner et est aujourd'hui
l'important c'est ça ou de transformer
savoir ça va évoluer la formation c'est
important de pouvoir former des gens
qu'ils soient qualifiés dont un salarié
de bain devra peut-être avoir plusieurs
métiers plusieurs vies pouvoir s'adapter
l'important c'est qu'il soit en activité
c'est qu'il ait de l'emploi et pour ça
il faut créer de l'emploi mais le
licenciement en soi ou c'est le chômage
qui est une la précarité le ciment ce
licenciement en soi et pas forcément un
drame si derrière il a retrouvé du
travail parce qu'il a la qualification
haddock à tout va bien mais moi je dis
encore une fois il n'ya pas je ne
connais pas un entrepreneur et j'en
connais beaucoup qui me disent j'ai
envie de licenciés jeunes et ils ont
tous une envie c'est empoché ses
croissance merci à bertrand à 2 crée
notre plateau et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
nous suivons évidemment cette actualité
car la mobilisation n'a pas touché que
les salariés les étudiants étaient
également mobilisés aujourd'hui dans les
ive et des différents syndicats
étudiants se sont donné rendez vous à la
gare de 50 ans ni vous pour un départ
vers la manifestation à paris lé
mouvement des jeunes socialistes
l'union des étudiants communistes
l'unef et étaient russes étaient réunis
en écoutant suite alexandre mais corps
président 2009 à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en veux pas
retourner en arrière tout simplement on
n'a pas envie non plus de travailler
plus pour gagner moins tout simplement
qu'à dix ans on se bat contre le cpe ce
gouvernement est contre le cpe et dix
ans plus tard ne pensait peu x 20 heures
de questions du qu'aujourd'hui on se
mobilise et dans la durée on va faire
monter la pression
chaque semaine le mec cassation
manifestations partout en france cas de
retrait mais total et ce projet de loi
aujourd'hui on est entre 50 et 60 à
partir des yvelines c'est très
encourageant ce que c'est la première
c'était les vacances pendant deux
semaines et pour autant on a réussi à
mobiliser 50 à 60 personnes qu'on va on
va rejoindre tous les autres sont
mobilisés à paris la prochaine pas
d'obligation c17 et je vous promets
qu'on se montre encore plus fort et une
autre mobilisation générale est prévue
normalement le 31 mars
l'unef quand elle appelle à une autre
journée d'action dans l'université
le 17 mars et depuis le lundi 7 mars
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines accueille les journées
handicap jusqu'à ce vendredi plusieurs
animations événements autour du handicap
rythme ces journées le but sensibiliser
la communauté universitaire au handicap
en essayant des pratiques sportives
adaptées ou en rencontrons des personnes
concernées mardi toute la journée
l'auteur des bd georges grard se
dépasser pour une séance de dédicaces
dans le hall de l'université il est le
premier à avoir mis en scène des héros
handicapés camille lambert la rencontre
et aide est un adolescent il vit dans
une cité il est une bande d'amis un
jeune garçon comme tous ceux de son âge
ou presque
voilà un deal en fauteuil roulant et
puis je me suis dit mais où hamid a des
copains qui on m'a dit que c'était tabou
de parler du handicap
alors j'ai rajouté du tabou j'ai fait un
grand black sam in obese un petit
maghrébins ilena segade charghi
malvoyants mais je voulais aussi parler
du handicap invisible donc j'ai fait
tommy tommy les déficients légèrement
autistes cette année la banda est fête
ses 10 ans il s'agit de la première
bande dessinée à mettre en scène des
héros ordinaires handicapé son auteur
était mardi 8 mars à l'université de
versailles saint quentin pour une séance
de dédicaces dans le cadre des journées
andy fac
avenue était organisée par l'association
étudiante cap évasion
je pense que c'est un bon vecteur parce
que c'est une bande dessinée qui peut
s'adresser autant aux adultes qu'aux
enfants trouvent ça bien de sensibiliser
les gens dès leur plus jeune âge ça
évite que les préjugés s'installe
durablement via la bd ça permet à chacun
de s'approprier les personnages
s'approprier l'histoire s'approprie des
situations et je pense que c'est
vraiment un très bon média et c'est très
bien très bien amenée dans les planches
parler du monde du handicap 127 et avec
un humour engagé une recette qui
fonctionne pour faire changer les
mentalités
les choses s'améliorent le regard
s'améliorent surtout on en parle de plus
en plus parler du handicap ses pairs
avancer la cause du handicap
montrez nous handicape ses peurs avancer
la cause du handicap on a le sentiment
que j'ai la bande dessinée a reçu le
prix en dix livres du meilleur ouvrage
jeunesse en 2007
le tome 5 de la banda aide est déjà en
préparation santé à présent réunir
trente mille témoignages d'étudiants
autour d'un questionnaire sur la santé
c'est l'objectif du projet ishare une
étude de l'ansés par les chercheurs de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines en partenariat avec la
faculté de bordeaux par le biais d'un
questionnaire sur internet
les étudiants répondent à des questions
sur de nombreux thèmes comme la
sexualité le sommeil ou encore leur
alimentation
le résultat de cette étude permettra
ensuite elle la mise en place d'un
programme d'amélioration de santé des
étudiants écoutez les précisions
recueillies par william l le but étant
de réunir trente mille étudiants
français qui répond à ce questionnaire
pour ensuite créer des statistiques les
envoyer à l'état et enfin mettre des
choses en place pour améliorer la santé
des étudiants l'accès aux soins les
remboursements le questionnaire est
confidentielle c'est à dire qu'on va
demander le nom mais après il va être
anonymisées et ensuite idéalement
demande aux étudiants de répondre dix
ans d'affilée donc en questionnaire par
an pour pouvoir voir l'évolution de la
personne au fur et à mesure en fonction
de l'âge et de la section dans laquelle
il nous on est principalement sur lui
fait est ce qu il ya aussi des actions
qui ce temps sur les bâtiments qui à
versailles il ya beaucoup et sidaction
sur bordeaux et éventuellement sur des
actions à paris contient les forums de
l'étudiant par exemple on peut être
présent et effectivement voilà ça va
durer le temps qu'on récolte les trente
mille étudiants offre à des actions
comme ça et revenons à présent sur la
journée internationale des droits des
femmes
hier soir le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et la
fédération française de cyclisme
organisé une soirée spécialement dédié
aux femmes démonstration de l'équipe de
france baptêmes de piste et ateliers et
être au programme la journée
internationale des droits des femmes
était aussi l'occasion pour la
fédération de présenter son plan de
féminisation de la discipline retour sur
cette soirée avec mélanie poquet le
cyclisme se conjugue aussi au féminin la
fédération française veut s'en donner
les moyens pour dépasser la barre des 10
% de licenciés
hier soir c'est au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines où elle a son
siège que la fédération l'a présenté
c'est par un plan d'urgence ans et un
plan d'action
c'est à dire qu'effectivement pour nous
la kz2 la féminisation c'est un axe
important de développement et donc la
volonté du président lappartient c'était
de mettre en place une stratégie qui
nous emmène jusqu'à tokyo
jusqu'aux jeux de tokyo donc une grosse
olympiades cinq ans pour faire bouger
les effectifs de la fédération notamment
les effectifs féminins lutter contre les
stéréotypes repenser la formation des
futurs athlètes sont quelques-uns des
axes de ce plan de féminisation et c'est
dans cette optique que la soirée entre
filles du vélodrome nationale a été
pensé avec comme marraine pour cette
première édition
pauline ferrand prévôt quadruple
champion du monde dans trois disciplines
différentes break que ça du mal mais on
va dire qu'on progresse
après on peut le voir aussi le nombre de
licenciés filles la fédération c'est
vrai que c'est vraiment en train
d'augmenter donc c'est une très bonne
chose
après je pensais aussi à travers ces
journées que j'en ai la con comment
inciter les filles à faire du vélo est
aussi leur dire que c'est pas qu'un
sport
enfin c'est pas un sport de garçons
c'est une fille peut aussi faire du vélo
donc c'est très important
le vélodrome et la ffc ou décidé de
mettre en place un créneau de pratiques
sur la piste 100% filmé et parmi ces
jeunes filles se trouve peut-être une
prochaine pauline ferrand prévôt et vous
avez dû le constater ces derniers jours
le temps n'est pas nécessairement de la
partie et pourtant il faut penser à
entretenir son jardin et donner de
l'attention à ces plantes le mois de
mars et nous avons propice à l'entretien
des rosiers quelques conseils pour ceux
qui n'ont pas la main verte
pour cela je l'accueille en plateau avec
moi mes amis poké bonsoir à mélanie
siens on sort flora valeur avant de
faire la taille de ses rosiers il faut
savoir le type que l'on possède
parce que chacun demande une taille
particulière il y en a trois types de
rezé lé grimpant les buissons et les
couvre-sol la taille se prépare en deux
étapes avant l'hiver il faut notamment
faire un nettoyage pour sélectionner les
branches enlever celles qui sont déjà
trop faible c'est la taille de mars par
contre qui la plus importante qu'elle
permet aux roses et de se renforcer de
faire réapparaître de nouvelles branches
france en moulin et l'ancien responsable
du potager du roi de versailles il nous
explique comment tailler les rosiers
grimpants et les buissons pour les rosés
grimpa en conserve les branches
principales
enfin renouvellement annuel et puis les
petites branches secondaires sont
taillés coupé à deux yeux à deux
bourgeons quant aux rosiers buissons
même époque bien sûr on prend soin d'eux
d'avoir un buisson à errer garder 4 5
belles branches et que l'on coupe qu'on
l'on redescend à 2,3 bourgeon en prenons
soin de conserver détaillées sur des
bourgeons qui regarde vers l'extérieur
alors là l'image qu'on va voir c'est la
taille des rosiers grimpants alors pour
le tailler une fois chaque fois à faire
des coupes franches qu'elle soit bien
propre et bien-être
avoir un bon sécateur qui est bien
aiguisé et propre ça évite d'abîmer la
plante il faut c taillée à chaque fois 2
à 3 mm au dessus du dernier bourgeon il
ne faut pas oublier de couper tous les
projets qui viennent du sol parce que ça
vient des racines ça peut abîmer aussi
là le rosier pour le rosé grimpons il
faut aussi penser à attacher
régulièrement les branches pour qu'ils
prennent ils prennent une belle forme et
ne pas oublier linceul l'ensoleillement
de la plante parce que c'est aussi très
important pour sa formation
alors on a parlé de la taille mais il
n'y a pas que ça qui compte mélanie mais
aussi l'entretien à faire il n'y a pas
qu'au mois de mars convoi s'occuper de
ces plantes qui se plante de son ordi de
son rosé parce qu'il peut être planté
dans un jardin il peut te poser dans un
pub dans un pot sur un balcon ça demande
beaucoup d'entretien
il faut aussi éviter les intérieurs ce
que je disais tout à l'heure ça a besoin
de lumière ça besoin d'humidité
cette fois je vous propose de vous
rendre chez marianne donné elle est
fleuriste à saint cyr l'école au mois de
mars est bien de faire un apport
d'engrais
donc on la taille justement on fait un
apport d'engrais qu'on va renouveler fin
avril
au niveau du pied après tout au long de
l'année notamment là quand les beaux
jours arrivent bien nettoyer le pied du
rosier puisque les rosiers à bien avoir
les pieds toujours bien propre au moment
de la floraison
il est important de veiller à bien
arrosé son gosier
c'est quand même une plante qui a besoin
d'un arrosage régulier
alors on a parlé des roises yémen mois
de mars est aussi l'occasion de prendre
soin de son jardin dans sa globalité
c'est aussi un mois propice aux semis
pour donner peut-être vie à votre
potager
oui parce qu'on peut en effet planté les
variétés précoces des pommes de terre
des roses d'oignons blancs ou encore
d'aspergés de petits pois et 2 carottes
on peut même faire des semis sous abri
comme celle de la salade du chou de
bruxelles ou encore de la betterave
vous pouvez aussi travailler votre
verger même s'il faut le dire nous
sommes à la fin au mois de mars celle
des pommiers et des poiriers sa touche
déjà à sa fin en deux fois président de
l'association jardins passions partagées
guyancourt elle nous a reçus chez à la
source dans son jardin et elle nous
donne encore quelques petits conseils à
partir du mois de mars commencent à
nettoyer un peu à faire un pas de vis
dedans lorsqu'il reste raconter des
choses qui restent dans le potager par
exemple les peaux rodez
et des betteraves puis après ben rejab
aurait un peu la terre surtout avec la
grelinette retourne pas vraiment la
terre autour d'un petit paumé pas
renverser voilà vous connaissez
maintenant quelques astuces pour
améliorer votre rosé et votre jardin
si vous voulez découvrir d'autres
astuces de jardinage l'association
jardins passions partage propose un
atelier ce samedi au centre alfred de
vigny de voisins-le-bretonneux le sujet
de ce samedi ce sont les plantes
tolérantes à la sécheresse
merci beaucoup mélanie est une autre
occasion de voir et d'observer de jolies
plantes c'est à la serre aux papillons
située à la queue-lez-yvelines elle a
rouvert ses portes le 20 février situé
dans la jardinerie poulain la tire de
nombreux curieux en admiration devant
ces lépidoptères
elle cherche également à sensibiliser le
public à la protection des papillons est
alors en apprendre un peu plus sur cet
insecte
regardez c'est dans ces mille mètres
carrés de végétation que les papillons
évolué lasserre accueille ces espèces
provenant d'élevages des philippines du
costa rica ou encore de malaisie mais
l'un d'entre eux reçoit plus de faveur
que les autres mon préféré c'est le
grand noir avec le bleu le grand jeu se
passant monde son nom c'est le morpho
bleu un des plus grands pensionnaires
ici avec 10 à 12 centimètres d'envergure
papillon bleu qui s'opposent
il ferme clm extérieur de ces aides
meetic par rapport à son environnement
et il ya également des petits dessins
dessus à l'extérieur qui ressemble à des
yeux là un vol rapide et d'extérieur des
ailes et marron donc ça se confirme avec
l'environnement et dans le pays
oui vie on l'appelle je te vois je te
vois plus la serre accueille
quotidiennement plus de 8 100 papillon
de différentes espèces et familles
chaque semaine 700 chrysalide sont
placés dans ces éclosent war puis
surveillé par les mamans de substitution
comme nathalie je suis grand mais j'ai
mené quelques doigts ou d'une crise
allait de cette taille et je suis prêt à
me voler un moyen pédagogique pour
parler de sciences aux enfants et dès le
plus jeune âge ils sont déjà incollable
sur l'insecte
ce qu'on ne sait plus de papillons la
serre aux papillons reste ouverte
jusqu'au 11 novembre
chaque année près de 50000 visiteurs se
pressent pour voir les lépidoptères eux
aussi ravis de voir de plus près leurs
visiteurs
à suivre tout de suite qui est ce que
votre magazine sur culturelle sur 50 ans
9 une présentée par sephora namani je
vous retrouve demain pour une nouvelle
édition du journal je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée